we got to talk about ian's favorite
subject yes so
this might be the the probably the
scariest story i've ever seen
one the one that truly freaks me out the
most wokeness
at fed's regional banks puts central
bank independence at risk
fed is supposed to operate free from
political influence
oh okay okay i love it whenever anybody
types that with a straight face
oh the federal reserve yeah no they
don't engage in politics at all
right right right why would they so uh
they say federal reserve banks and
atlanta boss in minneapolis recently
dedicated resources to social policy
policy
reflecting the political leaning of
officials who are neither elected nor
confirmed by the senate
the federal reserve's mission statement
mandates central bank to achieve maximum
employment
and stable prices while being free from
political influence
experience has shown that countries with
independent central banks achieve better
outcomes
pursuing a highly politicized social
agenda unrelated to monetary policy
is inflicting reputational damage on the
minneapolis atlanta and boston fed banks
and the federal reserve as a whole the
first thing i'm scared of but hold on
there's some good news here
is that the fed is the machine by which
they control things
and extract like essentially hidden
taxes on people printing money borrowing
money
and then your savings become worthless
and then they can use it to fund war and
other things like that
getting woke just means creepy dogmatic
authoritarianism
however it is also instability
it is wokeness is meritless it is about
instituting policy on the basis of what
feels good in our emotions
and our idea ideology as opposed to what
works
so it's kind of like well we've seen
wokeness
destroy institutions right we say get
woke go broke
so it may be scary what happens when the
federal reserve starts instituting
policy at a very massive level
but at the same time what if the fed
gets woke and goes broke
ah what what what happens huh what would
happen if i don't
know if the federal reserve board could
be any worse at their job
frankly and these guys have caused
nothing but booms and busts and
catastrophes
artificial booms and very real busts and
catastrophes my entire lifetime
i mean in the 1980s i'll never forget
that
in northwest austin they had built
entire neighborhoods
and entire shopping malls but it was
just the roads
and the foundations and then it stayed
like that for 10 years
it was another 10 years before they
built lakeline mall and we used to just
go out there and
camp and get drunk and skate and skate
dude i love i love it when you find
those like
old slabs yeah just like pre-constructed
buildings that are left for a long time
it's just
and it was just like that playground for
something like 10 years and then we all
lived through
the dot-com massive crash at the end of
the bill clinton years
where instead of cashing our peace
dividend and bringing the troops home
instead they printed a bunch of money
inflated the money supply
see here's the thing about inflation too
is as you say
it's hidden taxation right it's steph
it's the same reason it's against the
law for you and i to counterfeit money
it's because we're stealing the value of
our
neighbors dollars if we do that but
that's not the worst of it
the worst of it is that you get massive
price inflation
in certain sectors like housing
stocks that's happening fuel right now
that's what's happening again right now
yeah
so after the dot-com crash of 2000
they kept inflating housing and they
just poured more and more and more money
into housing to prevent that recession
from really kicking in
and then we had the massive crash of 08
that brought the whole dang world down
with it
then what'd they do qe one two three
four five
and just did nothing but ex expand the
money supply inflate inflate inflate and
just as rothbard teaches
they always try to somehow like prick
the bubble and slowly let the air out
but it's always a crash yep and in fact
though what happened this time was we
were due for a crash last year this year
sometime here real soon but what
happened was the governors donald trump
and the governors did it for us and
forced the recession not through high
interest rates but just by forcing the
clamp down the lockdown on the entire
economy
and so that meant all kinds of bad debts
were being cancelled off of bank books
right it's massively deflationary
to have in other words it was it was a
deliberately imposed
depression a recession on the economy so
then where does that leave us right now
with the lockdowns just being lifted a
massive increase
in the money supply it means we're right
back where we were in the year 2000 2001
right back where we were in the year
2009 just at the start of the next big
bomb so we're good
so we're now that's right we are yeah
unless
you're trying to to afford a place to
live and you can't
and which is why i don't know about
around here but in austin texas there
has
never been a homeless crisis like there
is right now and and in like
it's insane oh it's just unbelievable
and there's people living in tents up
and down the side of the road
everywhere but here's price inflation in
housing and now
and the and the mortgages have gone
through the roof now add in biden
offering up more stimulus and more tax
credits and more money for
for not working and what's happening we
see these stories where fast food
restaurants are saying
you know 500 bonus a thousand dollar
bonus come take the job
and people still won't do it i see from
a lot of leftists they're like oh
surprise surprise nobody wants to work
at fast food unless they're getting paid
a living wage
no dude you're getting paid 16 bucks an
hour to not work
which means i don't got to do anything
why would i take 16
an hour now to work when i'm already get
it to not work well but
plus the cost of living keeps going up
so but it's 15 an hour right what it
used to be but this is the problem
that's a surface
surface level problem what people don't
see is the same problems affecting steel
mills the same problem as
that is affecting mining raw materials
so while we can laugh that you can't buy
your your popeye's chicken sandwich
because nobody wants to work there
has anyone actually looked at the raw
materials that aren't getting produced
because the same problem is happening or
the farming that's not getting done
because the same problem is happening
you got a farmer and he's like i need
someone to work the fields to
to collect the crops to pick the certain
vegetables and it's like
how much you gonna pay i can pay 20
bucks an hour yeah i get 16 for nothing
so no thank you i won't do it
guess what you go to your store you
can't find bacon anymore you go to your
store you can't find vegetables
it's not just fast food it's hitting
everything and it's been happening since
last year because i've mentioned this
several times
i go on amazon i buy a tablet or i put a
tablet in my cart
i forgot i didn't buy it and then a day
or two later i get a notification
the price is increasing this product one
up like 150 bucks
that's how it's it's fast and it's and
you know
we can talk about the fed the printing
and all the stuff but then you have all
this spending
i think we're going to get hit real bad
and i think bitcoin is gonna
through the roof by the end of the year
don't look at me i'm not a financial
expert
i just look at what max kaiser is
talking about the guy's been right you
know a lot
so when you combine all of these things
so max keiser comes out and he's like
bitcoin is going to be his price point
is 220 by the end of the year maybe not
i don't know but i i max has been right
and i've listened to him in the past i'd
be very wealthy
but then i see what he's saying then i
look at the things we're seeing
this fed getting woke thing that
wokeness is not merit which means you're
gonna have people who can't do the job
that's already a ridiculous job the fed
which means potential destabilization on
whatever it is they're trying to do in
the first place is probably gonna get
worse
then you have the mass printing of money
you have no one wanting to work
seems to me like bitcoin is going to
skyrocket by the end of the year because
the
uh i'm sorry i'm sorry bitcoin's not
going to skyrocket
that dollar is going to collapse that's
a better way to put it
i think we need to repeal the federal
reserve act yeah
but we need a new a new system in place
like to withdraw
federal reserve notes and then give you
a cryptocurrency and response
give people two years to turn in all
their federal reserve notes
and then just make them all worth nil
after that so don't hoard your money
turn it in let's start a new economy
obviously they're going to track it if
it's a if it's a crypto
on the blockchain so every move you make
i don't know how they'll hide money off
offshore in in panama if it's a crypto
maybe they can't maybe that's the point
or maybe no maybe it's really easy to do
actually they actually have yeah
different kinds of cryptos too that
really do provide
a lot better security i think yeah
monero you can't track uh i think z
cash you can't travel no no z cash can
has has i think i could be wrong about
this but it has uh um
shadowed shadow accounts and visible
accounts so it works both ways you can
choose to
map like a matched account or none
that's really interesting actually and
look this is what frederick hayek said
was
rather than having i think murray
rothbard wanted 100
you know by law 100 gold reserve
standard and hayek just said
let there be competing currencies i
think this is the ron paul position
just what you do is you have to repeal
the legal tender laws
and you have to repeal the taxes on
different alternative currencies right
so if you're taxing capital gains on
silver and bitcoins and everything that
makes it impossible to use as a currency
really
or much more especially if you inflate
the dollar
and cause the cost of silver to go up
double right and then tax them on that
increase even though the value didn't
increase
they just printed twice the amount of
money so it looks like it and then
you lose a fourth of your money because
they printed twice as much and they've
been printing like crazy
i have to tell you the bad news is i
talked with robert higgs and this
conversation is probably
10 years old now or more but robert
higgs is the great libertarian economist
that wrote crisis in leviathan and he's
like listen man
forget the petro dollar forget you know
any of the different kind of
answers for why people are so dependent
on the dollar
they're dependent on the dollar because
they have been the dollar has been the
world reserve currency since the end of
world war ii
and it's gonna stay that way for a very
long time
because what it would take to stop that
would be for every central banker in the
world to wake up one day
and realize that all those hundred
dollar bills in their bank vault
are worth nothing and try to panic and
sell them all at the same time
but they're all painted into a corner if
any of them ever do that
then they're the one precipitating the
crisis and making it worse
and they're not going to be able to get
rid of the money before what if they
lose
hold on hold on what if all of these
bankers are sitting there with 100
in their bank account and then they're
like i don't want to be the one to sell
because it'll cost
my it'll cause my money to start losing
value so i won't be able to sell fast
enough
and then joe biden yells out churning on
a shabbat pressure and starts printing
money like crazy
then they're going to be like well he's
already doing it so dump the dollar
right people are going to want to get
out before it hits because he's already
tanking it right it could happen but
then there's also the question of
american military power
and are you gonna sell those hundred
dollar bills in your vault if we're
gonna kill you if you try it wasn't it
uh
you know we had gaddafi what did he want
to trade in dinars yeah he wanted to
essentially they still use the french
franc in the formerly french colonies of
africa yeah
even though the french are on the euro
they still use the french franc and then
he wanted to undermine that by switching
to a gold-backed dinar
yeah although he died yeah and i'm not
how that happens right i'm not really
sure
like how much evidence there is that
that was really the french's worry
i think sarkozy was really worried that
it was embarrassing
to him that he had stood by um
ben ali in tunisia all the way up until
he was forced to flee
at the at the very start of the arab
spring yeah and so he had a public
relations problem
and he was going to take it out on
gaddafi and then qaddafi had also
uh spent a bunch of money on sarkozy's
election campaign
so then he had the same problem john
mccain and joe lieberman had with
gaddafi was
they had sucked up to him and been too
nice to him recently and so now that he
was a hate figure again they had to turn
on him again
we can thank the obama administration
hillary clinton for absolutely
destroying north africa
absolutely right and look there was just
a piece the other day about the
isis sharia islamist state in northern
mali which is a direct consequence of
the war in libya it's got a whole
chapter in the book have you studied uh
sidney blumenthal much she he basically
sent
emails to hillary clinton this is part
of her email scandal she tried to delete
as much as possible but you can see in
podesta's
you know you can look them up sydney
blumenthal john podesta in fact
osprey global solutions which was hillar
which was uh
i think his company that he wanted it's
arms running i think the blumenthal
emails actually were released by the
state department
i think those were not the ones that
were leaked uh in the dnc leak in the
podesta league they were the
they were the state department jason
leopold sued under the freedom of
information act and they are
very incriminating yeah i mean he warns
her that they're rounding up and
murdering blacks just for being black on
the false accusation that they're
mercenaries
and this is in like april they kept the
war going another eight months after
that they could have called it off at
any time obama
forbade hillary working at all with
cindy blumenthal i thought he was bad
news
and hillary was like okay and then just
kept working with him anyway and he
would send her
battle tactics emails like you need to
invade libya
when we get there we'll set up my
company osprey global solutions to
fund the the revolutionaries you know
basically the american-backed
new military hillary's like okay she
just passes it on to her military bodies
that's that's the game it's disgusting
it's it's called
arms arms running uh war profiteering
it's illegal
as far as i know although maybe it's not
illegal i don't know
so hold on let's let's let's we'll bring
it back before we go super chats
this is what the woke people realized
there's no truth but power oh it's
illegal well they control the courts so
what does it matter anymore
hillary clinton like he like she's gonna
go to jail for anything thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you